BRADY HARAN: Hey, everyone.
This is a video I've been
wanting to make since
Numberphile started, really.
Because when you watch football,
or soccer if that's
what you want to call it, on
the TV I'm always amazed by
the number of statistics and
numbers they're able to throw
at you during the game.
How do they do that?
Who's recording it?
So what I've done is spent a
couple of days at a company
called Opta who collects
statistics from various
sports, including soccer.
Now in this film I want to give
you some idea just how
much information they collect
for every kick, every header,
every miss-kick, everything
that happens on the field
during a game of soccer.
To do this, I've chosen just one
kick as an example, and I
thought, seeing we're choosing
one, we should
make a special one.
So the one we're doing is a kick
by a guy called Andres
Iniesta in the 2010 World Cup
final, and it was the kick
that won the game.
It was the scoring of the
winning goal in a one-nil
victory against Holland.
Now unfortunately due to
copyright law, I can't show
you the goal, but it kind of
looked something like this.
Just like being there,
wasn't it?
But to a statistics expert,
especially one from Opta, the
goal looks more like this.
So enough from me.
Here's Sam talking you through
the anatomy, from a numbers
perspective, of the goal that
won the last World Cup final.
SAM GREEN: For me, I
obviously see it as
well, and I enjoy it.
But when we collect the data
I also see it as not just
numbers but a set of
data, basically.
And this is the details
of every shot in
that World Cup final.
So that was all the shots in the
game, and we're going to
look at, just in detail, about
Andres Initesta's, about the
winning goal-- well,
the only goal.
The key stat, the key number
for us in this
case is number 16.
It's completely random but for
us that's what a goal is.
If it's an event 16, we
know it's a goal.
BRADY HARAN: So for you,
16's a big deal.
SAM GREEN: 16 is the magic
number in football.
In Opta football, 16's
very important.
BRADY HARAN: When you're walking
around the street, and
you see number 16 on a house,
do you think, "goal"?
SAM GREEN: Do I think "goal"?
Yeah.
And then you've got number one
is "pass" for me, so that's
the one I see all the time.
So, yeah.
You do come to think about, when
you're watching a game
you'll think about it in the
way the guys collect it and
the way it looks in
the database,
which is a mixed blessing.
13 is a miss.
So you get it off target.
What else is there, off
the top of my head?
Three is a dribble.
It's one of the more exciting
things that can happen.
So we know it's a goal.
It's number 16.
We can see when it happens,
in the fourth period.
So it's the second period of
extra time, the fourth overall
period of the game.
When it happens, towards
the end.
We know this his ID, so I know
this is Andres Iniesta, 12237.
And the team that took the
shot obviously was Spain.
So outcome 1, in some things
that we collected, there's
obviously whether it
was a good thing or
completed or not.
Obviously for a goal, we know
it was completed, so
it's outcome 1.
The most crucial bit of
information, besides the fact
it was a goal, is where
it happened.
So, these are our coordinates
for where it
happened on the pitch.
I can kind of show you what
a 9, 62.3 looks like.
BRADY HARAN: I see
your drawings--
SAM GREEN: Yeah, really
terrible.
This is why I do
maths all day.
It's already gone wrong.
And the six-yard box.
The goal is probably
about here.
It's going to go about
here, about 9, goes
down to about there.
62.3 tells me it's over here.
This is 50, in the middle,
so I know 62.3 is
somewhere out here.
There's an authentic recreation
of Iniesta.
I'll do him with one little
strand of hair, because that's
about all he's got.
So that tells us something
about it, but there's
obviously a lot more
that happened as to
why it was a goal.
BRADY HARAN: What if
you caught up now?
SAM GREEN: So, here we've got
the sub-aspects of the shot.
So with this extra data I can
see where it went in the goal,
the y and z coordinates.
So these are the goals.
So he stuck it about here.
He stuck it the other
side of the goal.
And it went not very high
off the ground.
So he probably stuck it
around about here.
We have, before he took
the shot, there.
We now know it went pretty much
in the bottom corner.
Not quite tucked in,
but certainly to
the side of the keeper.
I know it was assisted,
and that it was
an intentional assist.
I know it went low to the
keeper's left, which makes
sense given that he shot it from
over here and we know it
ended up over here.
Went with one bounce, he hit it
with his right foot, hit it
on the volley, and it came
from a counter attack.
And I also know the keeper
touched the ball.
As memory serves it was
a small touch first,
Stekelenberg.
So that's the anatomy
of the goal.
That's all the information
we collect about it.
There are different shots,
different goals that'll have
different bits of information.
But that's what we know
about this shot.
So we can then use that.
We can put all that information
in and see how
likely was it that Iniesta would
have scored that goal,
the goal that ended up winning
the World Cup.
BRADY HARAN: Now at this point
I guess a lot of you would
like to see a bit more about how
the numbers are collected,
how they harvest the statistics
during the game.
And I actually spent an entire
match day at Opta.
I was able to watch them during
the games, how they do
it, how they interact with
the commentators on TV.
That's going to be in
an upcoming video.
But for now I thought I'd hear a
bit more from Sam about what
he does with the statistics
after the game, and maybe a
bit more about that Andreas
Iniesta goal.
SAM GREEN: To take an example,
we go back to the Iniesta one,
the model that we developed
says, OK, that chance was
actually a really good chance
for it, as they go.
It was about a 30% chance of
being a goal before we know
anything about where
he even put it.
Just to get the ball in that
good a position off a
counterattack is a very good
chance of scoring, 30%.
It might not sound like that
much but a average shot's
probably around 8 to 10%.
So this is a really
good chance.
But if we changed a few things,
if we took the shot
back to here--
it's the edge of the
18-yard box--
and the shot was here, it goes
from maybe 30% here down to
about, I don't know, 12% or so
it drops to about there.
Equally, if we brought the shot
inside, so he's got the
full range of the goal to choose
from, goes from 30%,
but now it might go up to
about as high as 50%.
I've developed a model which
takes into account all these
kinds of factors about what
we know about the shots.
Because we've got such a
huge backlog of shots
and details of them.
BRADY HARAN: Can
you still enjoy
watching a game of football?
SAM GREEN: Absolutely.
More so.
I think you look at things
in a different way.
You think about what players
are doing and where they're
doing it and how they're
doing it, and what
does that lead to.
You still enjoy it and you still
watch the game, and it's
still exciting.
And when there's a great goal or
a great save you still have
the same reflex reactions to
everything of excitement.
But you just think about
the game in a
slightly different way.
I think for me it's more fun.
I think it's better.
But personal taste, I guess.
I think the Holy Grail with
this kind of football
analytics and what I'm doing and
what lot of other people
are doing is something, you want
to get to one number that
broadly encapsulates that
player, and that player's
value, or at least
on pitch value.
There could be other things--
age and contract which holds the
effect, their value to the
opposing team.
But purely on what they do,
value like baseball has Wins
Above Replacement.
And I think that's kind of where
I'm trying to take it.
I think probably other
people are trying
to do the same thing.
BRADY HARAN: This must be like
the best job in the world!
SAM GREEN: Yeah, pretty much.
I mean, I didn't want to say
it in the interview, but if
they just gave me access to
the database I'd have been
pretty happy with that.
They didn't need to pay me.
But they seem to want to do
that, so that works for me.
BRADY HARAN: So thanks to the
guys from Opta, and a
reminder, we'll have another
video soon where we go behind
the scenes on match day, which
is far more exciting.
But for now, thank you for
watching, and some more of the
details about the statistics
can be found on the blog.